[Music]
mistaken point
around us missed
underfoot petrified deep time rises and
Wealth's to prod our souls here and
there breaking into sudden vow relief
88% of Earth's history is called the
Precambrian age mistaken point is the
only world heritage site for that vast
span of time what's so important about
the reserve is that these fossils
they're the first large complex
multicellular organisms known in the
history of life the main fossil site is
absolutely amazing our particular
sequence of rocks here is between 590
and 560 million years ago
they're preserved on the upper surfaces
of the beds as imprints you're walking
across what once was a deep sea ocean
floor
it's quite amazing as one person who
said it's like you're almost scuba
diving over this very strange deep-sea
ecological community
[Music]
question arises why did they evolve in
that type of environment so that many
unanswered questions
when you're physically in mistake and
point you can feel the power of the land
you can see the crashing of the rocks
you can on this use your imagination to
imagine the immensity of the power that
it took to thrust the ocean floor up
onto the land
I think I'll always be making work about
the second point I have such a strong
attachment to that place
when I'm working on the surface of the
things and I'm running it through the
machine I'm just building layers and
layers and layers to think about 575 you
know a million years like it's just so
ancient that I can't even imagine what I
can do as an artist is try to translate
that deep time and that the passage of
time in the layering of the work
[Music]
back here in the Anthropocene the mist
is thickening to drizzle the bedrock
darkens deepening the contrast but shall
we call this antique frond part fern
part feather part Art Nouveau and brand
new Brea urgent and enigmatic as an
Oracle
[Music]
you